every child in this wooden shack in Gaza
City has lived under the Israeli
blockade since they were born
for them going to school is more than
just learning its respite from the daily
difficulties they face outside when the
global pandemic shot Gaza schools in
March 13 year old fishermen knew she had
to do something she formed her own
classroom and started to teach others
another one have been in me as I wanted
to bring them here and to teach them
this is my talent I have one girl in
first grade and if she's absent from
school she'll forget how to hold a pen
and how to write so I wanted to help
them develop and to make sure they don't
forget what they've already learnt at
school she only had four students to
begin with now she has 15 today's lesson
is Arabic but special also teaches
English and maths I keep up with my
classes here as well as on the Ministry
of Education website where they post
videos so I watched those two it's not
the first time Gaza 700 or so schools
have been forced to close thousands of
children missed out last year because of
his radio strikes this year all teachers
were prepared well before the first co
vid 19 case was recorded they started
giving lessons online and using the
radio with the state of emergency
extended to June the fifth other schools
have been turned into quarantine centers
while this classroom setup may be small
first row is dreaming beats she hopes to
open her own educational center one day
to help other marginalized children
Sarah hi it's al Jazeera